[Music]
[Applause]
ESPN reporter and host Malika Andrews
leading the coverage for her show NBA
today live on site from Denver game five
tonight tip-off 8 30 Eastern on ABC
Malika thanks for joining us uh give me
the game plan as you go into an
interview with the joker you had great
questions but you know you're going to
be like bam out of Bio trying to guard
him here bring up horses that's that's
thing number one it's something that we
have in common and so I feel like that
has it had to be on the list and I was
asked several times if if horses was
going to come up and I had to say
absolutely but um no you know for for
for me I feel like the the general
audience is still getting to know Nicola
jokic a little bit which is wild to say
about a a two-time MVP about a player
that has been an All-Star over and over
that's one of the greatest players if
not the greatest player that's playing
right now I feel like his personality we
are still getting to know little
glimpses of it outside of the horses
outside of the the sombor shuffle or the
sombor sling or whatever you want to
call it and so for me it was just like
how can I get this guy to tell some
stories
um because I know that they are great I
know that he always has his teammates
laughing and chuckling and and he's what
he does on the court Dan is just it's so
insane that how can we get to know this
guy a little bit better and sometimes
great players can't describe what makes
them great that they don't they just do
it it's it's reactionary and plus I
don't know if he wants to I don't know
if you've sat down and interviewed
somebody who's that apprehensive to talk
about Legacy or any you know he he wants
to deflect but I yeah I mean he fits in
a small category everybody's about their
brand and let me tell you how great I am
he doesn't want any part of that no I I
fully believe that when Nikola jokic is
done playing basketball he is going to
be done playing basketball it's so clear
what's important to him it is his
daughter it is his family it is his
brothers who show up every game and you
can hear them no matter where you are at
in the arena
um it it is his teammates and it's
winning but it's not winning in a way
that he needs to talk about it every
single day and that's part of what makes
him remarkable especially in this age
like you talked about when I asked him
about you know his D he wants to talk
about his teammates that's the thing
when you ask him about himself he's
always going to say well this is how
someone else helped me to get to this
point he even talked about it in his
General Media session yesterday when he
was asked about winning and who he wants
to share it with he says it's the people
that have always been there he's a guy
who hangs with his day ones and that's
it and that's what he's going to
continue to do plus if you're around
athletes from war torn
countries there's no nonsense about them
like they you know Giannis was oh you
know is this a disappointment this is
somebody who grew up having one meal a
day like you know I I know
disappointment I know struggle I know
adversity their their perspective is
different than ours
there's just a unique appreciation it
seems for what a player like Nicola a
player like Giannis who I've had the
great privilege of interviewing over and
over a perspective that they keep that I
think maybe comes from a place of we
weren't always told that this was going
to happen we were not put into a funnel
when we were a 10 11 12 13 year old
playing in AAU basketball and don't get
me wrong it is incredibly difficult as
you know to make the NBA there is no uh
sure bet just like you were talking
about you can't say for sure the Miami
Heat or counted out tonight there's no
for a bet you're going to make it to the
NBA but there is this inherent belief
that's been fed to many many young
players that wasn't fed someone like
Nickelodeon sure in part that's because
he was playing water polo up until he
was in his mid-teens right and that's
part of where we get these incredible
passes from is the other sports that he
played
um but I think that that's a big part of
it too he's centered around something
that is isn't just making the biggest
contract that he is going to make in the
NBA we had a conversation yesterday
about if I could about he almost when
when Nicola was drafted 41st as everyone
knows a Taco Bell commercial was playing
when he was drafted right and we didn't
even get to see the footage playing on
live television because he was drafted
41st overall so he's drafted and he
actually he didn't plan to come over to
Denver he planned to stay over in Spain
he basically had a contract that was
essentially signed with the Spanish team
he was playing for Mega at the time
um and the Spanish officials they came
to watch him play his plan was to be
stashed for a couple of years and as we
know sometimes players were stashing
never make it over to the NBA he had the
worst game of his life he says when
those Spanish officials came to watch
him play Four Points three rebounds
couldn't defend you know a broomstick
and so the Spanish officials said we're
good we don't want this guy and only
then did he say all right I guess I'll
report back to Denver we might not have
seen this guy play like that's what
we're talking about when we're talking
about nickel jokic and now he is
dazzling on the highest stage and his
one went away from the franchise's first
title and I think that's the real
benefit of all of this we're talking to
Malik Andrews ESPN host uh NBA today
live on site from Denver that'll be uh
tip off tonight 8 30 Eastern on ABC that
we're almost forced to watch him
because you have to go out of your way
to watch him and even at the mothership
you're not leading with Denver
highlights because what are you going to
show a nice crisp bounce pass and and so
he's caught up in the Highlight culture
but this forced everybody when he played
the Lakers now you have to watch him
because you're tuning in for the Lakers
whether you love them or not and then by
proxy you the number of people have been
like man he is good
yeah he won two MVPs but they almost had
to see it to validate like yeah he is
really good he just is economically
great and when you say like I had I
yelled at Kendrick Perkins
um through the TV every day yeah when
he's saying oh he's you know he's
patting his stats I'm going
there's 50 players in the NBA who took
more shots per game than he did during
the regular season
he is incredible that's not patting your
stats
the one we kind of all joke about right
is the one Rebound in next where it's
like oh okay like maybe we're gonna go
there but no that's that's not what this
that's not what this player is right I
do think Nick Lukas I've been really
lucky so my first ever internship uh in
the business was at The Denver Post it
was Jamal Murray's rookie year and so I
was lucky to get a glimpse of what that
team was going to look like that then it
was vastly different right this was the
Jamir Nelson the Gary Harris uh uh team
with whether or not Jamal Murray is
going to be able to exist in this
ecosystem and then my very first
Christmas Day game was for ESPN
Sidelines was in Denver but I do think
Nicole jokic I don't want to um overly
defend my colleagues but I do think he's
a player you have to see in person to
fully appreciate because I can tell you
on TV that little touch pass in game one
to Aaron Gordon I'm sure that that
resonated no matter where you are but
seeing it in person there was this like
Collective gasp of the entire audience
and this is Denver Nuggets fans who have
been watching this guy play since he
came into the league of like how did he
defy physics that way how does that even
work and so there's this your
appreciation for what he can do gets
taken to another level when you watch
him in person because
um he isn't going to be the sexiest
dunker you know he talks about how he
couldn't do a push-up right when he came
into the league he had to work with
Felipe to get his conditioning uh to
where it is now
but my god when you watch the complete
game that he puts together he is up
there you know with the greats yeah we
talk about basketball IQ you can
actually see IQ when you watch him
because they're just little things that
he does and he plays the angles I'm
always telling my guys that there's
certain guys who see the game in a
different way than we do and that's why
they're amongst the greatest of all time
they just see angles they they see
openings they they they learn how to
take advantage of all those things and
you know then I'm looking at the Miami
Heat we gave them credit for the heat
culture and all the undrafted players
but then it feels like the undrafted
players are playing and showing you why
they shouldn't have been drafted because
they're not able to kind of keep this up
on a consistent basis what is what is
missing from Miami what has been missing
in your opinion yeah I mean I'm not sure
you know I think right Richard Jefferson
has his recipe for success you need two
games from your stars you need one game
you're not supposed to win and one game
from your others and I think that
whether or not your others are undrafted
is is somewhat irrelevant but Miami you
know
I wonder I know Jimmy Butler says you
don't care about my ankle health and
neither do I so it's not going to be an
excuse but when you watch the Milwaukee
series the way he was driving the way he
was attacking and even on his drives in
game four he oftentimes would then kick
it out and so I do Wonder a little bit
if you know the greatest I believe
arguably the greatest individual Jimmy
Butler game we saw was game five in the
NBA bubble
um I was lucky enough to be there when
he's hanging over the stanchion
essentially plays All 48 minutes and
wills this Miami Heat team that was hurt
that was struggling uh to force the
Lakers to a game six that they
ultimately lost
just wonder if Jimmy has that I know
Jimmy doesn't care if I wonder or you
wonder whether or not he has
yeah but I have to ask that question
because as much as you need a game from
a Gabe Vincent from a Max Bruce from a
Duncan Robinson to be able to contribute
and give you that extra pizzazz
it's got to start with Jimmy and he
hasn't been at the level that he has
been and he says he's fine so you've got
to take him sort of at face value for
that but you have to wonder if he has
one more left in the tank because that's
what it's going to take
the biggest story in the off season that
intrigues you the most Dame Lillard
Chris Paul James Harden uh Kyrie Irving
oh yeah and Kyrie out of those out of
those four who is going to make the
biggest headline
who's going to make the biggest headline
probably Kyrie Irving
I am very curious about Chris Paul right
we're talking about a future Hall of
Famer
um who hasn't quite gotten to the
Mountaintop yet
um you don't think Dame is traded
I mean James said over and over again
Portland Portland Portland and the day
that Dame is traded I would be surprised
I will be and just because it's not
because I think it's impossible but
because we've sort of heard this shatter
so many times before I'm a little bit at
the point of I'll believe it when I see
it and I don't mean that disrespectfully
it's just more about there's been so
many conversations like this for so many
years ramping up to this point and it
doesn't feel like it's ever gotten to
that inflection and just gotten there
and so I sort of feel the same way this
year Kyrie stays in Dallas
yeah I think Kyrie stays in Dallas it
makes the most you know Financial sense
for him and I think that they need him
they Luca is on the clock they need to
prove that they can keep Stars keep
Kyrie happy and get to a point that they
can win they need to go out and get some
defensive anchors they need to go out
and fill or fill around but I think that
Kyrie Irving should stand house why
would James Harden want to go to Houston
as opposed to staying with the team that
has can contend if I had that if I had
that answer I think I would be more of a
betting woman but uh if my my best
understanding right is that he went to I
covered him in Brooklyn he went there to
win he went to Philadelphia to be in
what he felt was a less volatile Locker
more apt to win situation it didn't
totally work there was enough butting
heads with with coaching staff with with
this and that that at some point you
know he happiness rules the day and in
Houston he will be welcomed backed it
seems like with open arms
um but the question that will follow him
there is then is the window on winning
just closed because clearly Houston even
hiring a great coach like eme udoka just
doesn't seem to be in that position at
all right now do you ever get knocked
over when you're doing sideline
um yeah I have actually I've gotten ball
in the head but it didn't fully
didn't fully knock me over I've gotten
taken out by Richard on set
um but never been fully knocked over
just by just falling uh we want to
attach Chris Paul to the Lakers because
that that gets clicks are are you are
you attaching Chris Paul to the Lakers
I'm not so sure I mean first of all I
don't think the Lakers are gonna do and
and you know you need Bobby marks on for
all the financials of all of this but
they did a a three star and I know it's
a vastly different player but they did
the three-star experiment with with
Russell Westbrook LeBron and Anthony
Davis and so depending on how those
financials work out and what they can
keep which I'm I I would need to look at
they've learned their lesson there I
believe that that's they're not going to
sacrifice depth and that's by the way
that's a that's a decision that more and
more teams are going to have to make now
with the new CBA essentially you're
locked into two stars and then filling
out if you get three it's really really
hard to fill out the rest of the team
so I would be a little bit surprised
because of that and then also we've seen
Lebron team up with with his you know
Banana Boat Brethren uh Carmelo Anthony
being one of them players she's close to
and hasn't always panned out the way
that we all maybe thought it would and
so I think between those two things I if
that happened if Adrian was asked you
reported that I'd look down on my phone
I would say oh I would not I would
be like oh yeah of course duh like I saw
that coming
great stuff uh have fun today and uh
tonight and thanks for joining us Malika
and by the way Nikola yokich new horse
win or lose he says I like that I like
what's he gonna name the horse that's
what I want to know
Dan Patrick no I would think I would
think
Jamal
I like it although then when you get
into the ride I think you know what
we're just gonna
I'm gonna get on Jamal uh yeah you're
right Malika Andrews the mothership uh
NBA Today Live from Denver game five
tonight tip off at 8 30 Eastern on NBC